[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hahlweg
guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei sind
wie auch noch was König für den Sport
kommt und wir haben unter anderem diese
Themen für Sie
mögliche Arbeitsausfälle durch Omikron
um Engpässe zu vermeiden prüft
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach eine
kürzere Quarantäne Pflicht
Hochwasser in Deutschland Waldbrände in
den USA schmelzende Gletscher
2021 war ein Jahr der Wetter extreme
und fragwürdige Einkaufstour wegen des
Feuerwerk Verkaufsverbot in Deutschland
besorgen sich manche ihre Böller im
Nachbarland Belgien
[Musik]
durch die Omikron Variante ist mit einer
schlagartigen Erhöhung der
Infektionswelle zu rechnen das schreibt
das Robert-Koch-Institut heute das
bedroht auch die Funktionsfähigkeit und
zwar nicht nur von Kliniken wenn immer
mehr Menschen infiziert oder in
Quarantäne sind drohen flächendeckende
Personalausfälle um das zu verhindern
wird jetzt überlegt infizierte oder
Kontaktpersonen schneller wieder
arbeiten zu lassen
aktuell müssen sich alle Corona
infizierten in Deutschland mindestens 14
Tage isolieren auch wenn sie keine
Symptome zeigen um Personalengpässe zu
vermeiden haben einzelne Länder die
Quarantänezeit für infizierte ohne
Symptome schon reduziert Spanien und
Großbritannien etwa auf 7 die USA auf 5
Tage Christoph destere berechnet
Omikron und die Infrastruktur schwierig
Beispiel USA um Weihnachten rum zu viele
infiziert die Piloten gab es zu viele
Kollegen sicherheitshalber gleich mit in
Quarantäne Ergebnis tausende Flüge
fielen aus kein frohes Fest auch die New
Yorker U-Bahn musst ihren Betrieb
drosseln und so drängt sich die Frage
auf wie viel Quarantäne Bremse durch
Omikron kann das öffentliche Leben
wegstecken Antwort der WHO die
meisten Infizierten werden etwa 6 Tage
lang positiv sein dann aber kaum noch
ansteckend ist jetzt muss jedes Land für
sich entscheiden ob es den Betroffenen
erlaubt sich vorzeitig aus der
Quarantäne raus zu testen und so denkt
auch Deutschland über eine Abkürzung
nach gestern etwa der
Gesundheitsminister
wir haben eine dynamische Situation das
ist schon ein bisschen anders als was
wir für 1 Woche gehabt haben und wir
müssen uns jetzt überlegen wie gehen wir
damit um was bedeutet das zB für die
Quarantäne gerade mit Blick auf die
kritische Infrastruktur Feuerwehr
Polizei Energieversorgung etwa die
Experten der Regierung brüten derzeit
über Vorschlägen was infizierte selbst
betrifft aber auch deren Kontaktpersonen
ein Unterschied unterstreichen Virologen
weil Menschen die sich infiziert haben
mit Cola wäre ich im Augenblick
zurückhaltend Isolation oder Quarantäne
auch für systemkritische Bereiche
aufzuheben wann das ist das bei Menschen
die Kontaktpersonen sind hier kann man
eben darüber nachdenken unter bestimmten
Bedingungen in bestimmten Situationen
eben die Quarantäne aufzunehmen in den
Krankenhäusern herrscht auch eher
Skepsis
wenn es darum geht Menschen aus der
Quarantäne früher herauszuholen die als
infizierte getestet wurden dann kann ich
mir das nur dann vorstellen wenn diese
Person quasi unersetzlich sind die
Omegon Welle wird also organisatorisch
ein heikler Balanceakt gilt es doch das
öffentliche Leben für alle am Laufen zu
halten aber möglichst niemanden
einzelnen zu gefährden
schauen wir auf die aktuellen Corona
zahlen die können allerdings laut RKI
feiertagsbedingt unvollständig sein die
Gesundheitsämter melden
42770 Neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
Tages
383 Todesfälle kamen hinzu die Inzidenz
steigt wieder leicht auf
207,4 die Zahl der neu gemeldeten
Omicron Fälle stieg um
3619 ein Plus von
28% im Vergleich zum Vortag
die sogenannten Spaziergänge von Corona
Leutnant und Impfkritiker nimmermehr
Kommunen bundesweit verbieten diese so
auch die Stadt München dennoch sammelt
sich gestern Abend etwa 5.000 Teilnehmer
zu mehreren Demos die die Polizei
auflöste insgesamt gab es mehr als 700
Anzeigen
die Bundesregierung stuft Italien Malta
und Kanada ab neue als hochrisikogebiete
ein wegen hohe Infektionszahlen dort für
Reisende heißt das wenn sie nicht
vollständig geimpft oder genesen sind
müssen sie nach der Heimkehr in
Quarantäne bereits gebuchte Reisen
können durch die Einstufung leichter
kostenlos storniert werden aktuell noch
eine Warnstufe höher liegt Südafrika
allerdings voraussichtlich nur noch bis
Dienstag in Südafrika wurde Ende
November erstmals die Omikron Variante
nachgewiesen kaum ein Land hat
entsprechend mehr Erfahrung damit und so
lohnt ein Blick auf die aktuelle Lage
aus Johannesburg berichtet Sandra Theis
die covid Lage ist entspannt in der
Provinz Gauteng mit ihrem Metropolen
Johannesburg und Pretoria hier lag das
Epizentrum von Omikron als es Ende
November losgehen inzwischen gehen die
Infektionszahlen zurück Experten und
Ärzte ziehen vorsichtig positive
Schlüsse Omikron
verursacht hier in der medizinischen
Grundversorgung beim durchschnittlichen
Patienten vielen mildere Symptome als
Delta
selbst die Patienten die ins Krankenhaus
müssen können bei Omicron auf mildere
Verläufe hoffen wir haben die schwere
verglichen ab der Aufnahme im
Krankenhaus wir haben beobachtet wie
viele Patienten Sauerstoff brauchten auf
die Intensivstation mussten oder schwer
erkrankten und wir haben 30 bis 40%
weniger schwere Stelle bei Omicron als
bei Delta registriert
die Wissenschaftler warnen aber davor
die Ergebnisse aus Südafrika eins zu
eins auf andere Länder zu übertragen je
nach Altersstruktur Immunität und impf
Situation könnten die Auswirkungen
anderswo auch anders aussehen
doch jetzt zunächst zum Thema Corona
dillane Maxwell Ex Partnerin des
Verstorbenen US Multimillionärs Jeffrey
Epstein ist schuldig gesprochen worden
wegen Beihilfe zum sexuell missbraucht
die Geschworenen am Gericht in New York
sind überzeugt dass sie Apps die über
Jahre hinweg und systematisch auf dessen
Anwesen Minderjährige zu führte das
Strafmaß steht noch nicht fest der
60-Jährigen droht jahrzehntelanger Haft
2021 war ein Jahr der extreme wegen der
Pandemie aber auch wegen des Wetters in
Deutschland zeigte sich das am
schlimmsten Mitte Juli bei der tödlichen
Flutkatastrophe im Aartal überhaupt
practice Starkregen das Wetter mehr gab
es bei uns zuletzt nur 2018 und die
Temperatur lag 0,9 Grad über dem
Durchschnitt bedeutet es war zu warm zum
elften Mal in Folge Susana Santina mit
einer Bilanz
Flutkatastrophe nach tagelangen starken
Regenfällen mit Judy vielen in der
Region um ah und Erft durchschnittlich
am Tag mehr als 90 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter so viel wie noch nie seit
Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnungen
Starkregen kann erst seit 2001 gemessen
werden und in diesem Jahr gab es fast
den Rekord
38° gab es hier noch nie
dramatische Entwicklung auch beim
sogenannten Gletscher des Weltuntergangs
in der Antarktis ohne ihn würden
Küstenregionen im Meer versinken jetzt
haben Forscher Risse entdeckt würde der
gesamte Gletscher abschmelzen würde sich
der Meeresspiegel um 65 cm erhöhen das
führt dazu dass Küstenstädte überflutet
werden und im Fall von Stürmen also wenn
ein Hurrikan z.b. Auftritt das dann der
Meeresspiegel deutlich höher ist und uns
zu viel größere Zerstörung führt und das
ist ein globales Problem
2021 war das Jahr der extreme mit
zahlreichen Tornados Regen und Hitze
Rekorden der Klimawandel ist in vollem
Gange
auf dem Strommarkt gibt es derzeit
einige Turbulenzen und die können Kunden
teuer zu stehen kommen viele vor allem
kleine Anbieter müssen nämlich ihren
Strom sehr teuer einkaufen auf so teuer
dass sie Insolvenz anmelden müssen der
Kunde landet dann automatisch bei seinem
Grundversorger und der verlangt meist
deutlich mehr für den Strom Ralf
Gottmann berichtet die Nachricht
verkündete der Stromanbieter Stromio den
Kunden gerade erst auf der Homepage
Stromio liefert keinen Strom mehr der
Anbieter ist nur einer von bundesweit 13
Unternehmen die ihre Strom oder Gas
Lieferung dieses Jahr eingestellt haben
sie begründen das mit den derzeit hohen
beschaffungs Preisen am Energiemarkt die
Kunden werden dann automatisch vom
lokalen Grundversorger beliefert
allerdings zahlen Sie dort in der Regel
deutlich mehr sie müssten selber
kurzfristig teuren Strom zu kaufen heißt
es als Begründung von vielen Stadtwerken
nach unserer Auffassung ist klar es
liegt eine Vertragspflichtverletzung vor
nach unserer Rechtsauffassung hat der
Anbieter der bisherige Anbieter die
Pflicht das zu zahlen ob sie das machen
werden Dir sehen und wahrscheinlich
werden das irgendwann Gerichte
entscheiden ob Strom oder Gas generell
gilt Verträge mit kurzen Laufzeiten
abschließen und vor allem keine
Vorauszahlung leisten denn weitere zwei
Dutzend Anbieter haben bereits
angekündigt noch in diesem Jahr ihre
Strom oder Gas Lieferung einstellen zu
wollen
1000 Jahr ist heute schon zu Ende
gegangen mit dem letzten Handelstag und
mit Zahlen die AnlegerInnen und Anleger
ermutigen dürften in 2021 war trotz
Corona Lieferengpässen und
Fachkräftemangel ein gutes Jahr für
Aktionäre woran es liegt Stefan
Schlösser erklärt
Bulle und Bär die Wappentiere der Börse
stehen für steigende und fallende Kurse
in diesem Jahr hat der bulle klar
gesiegt trotz Pandemie trotz
Lieferketten Problemen die Kurse sind
gestiegen der DAX ist mit rund 13700
Punkten ins Jahr gestartet heute steht
dabei über
15801 sattes Plus von 15,8%
[Musik]
Neuling Sartorius oder auch Merck aus
Darmstadt die großen Gewinner angesichts
der Pandemie kaum verwunderlich Aktien
bieten weiterhin Chancen auch für
Kleinanleger
vor dem Baumarkt in Kelmis an der
belgisch-deutschen Grenze stehen sie in
Doppelreihe und die Schlange der Kauf
Villingen zieht sich dann noch durch das
gesamte Gebäude
Verkaufsverbot in Deutschland hier in
Belgien ist alles erlaubt und es gibt
was zischt und knallt und explodiert da
fährt man gerne mal stundenlang da sind
Deutschland überhaupt keine
Möglichkeiten gibt irgendwie großartig
was zu knallen zu holen ich brauche das
nicht aber die Kinder freuen sich
eigentlich auch Silvester und deswegen
sind wir drei Stunden gefahren woher
kommen sie
aus Deutschland
Warendorf
natürlich
mit
böllerverbot Zonen wer dort zündelt
riskiert hohe Geldstrafen an allen
anderen Stellen darf man Böllern aber
Knallkörper ohne eine deutsche
Zertifizierung wie das sogenannte
bannsiegel sind grundsätzlich verboten
eine ganz andere idee für morgen wäre
das Silvesterkonzert aus der Semperoper
in Dresden
Filmmusiken Evergreens Musicals aus den
20er Jahren ohne Publikum dafür mit
Starbesetzung Thomas Berschweiler bei
der Generalprobe dabei
[Musik]
das gab es so tatsächlich noch gar nicht
an Silvesterkonzert in der Dresdener
Semperoper wegen Corona ohne Publikum
der Dirigent wird es vermissen
[Musik]
wenn es so Stellen gibt wo dann das
Publikum mit Amazon dass den Atem anhält
das merkt man schon und wenn keins da
ist ist natürlich keins daher dafür
kleiden Lichttechniker den Saal in
Atmosphäre bereit für die Reise ungefähr
100 Jahre zurück eine Reise durch
Filmmusiken wie hier aus Metropolis
durch Musicals und Operetten
die Sächsische Staatskapelle Dresden
hanna-elisabeth Müller sei mir pirgo und
Igor Levit singen und spielen die Corona
und all die anderen ernsten Themen des
Jahres einfach beiseite
wir werden auch das nächste Jahr von all
diesen Dingen reden und wir werden auch
das übernächste Jahr wahrscheinlich
davon reden aber noch einmal
es ist essentiell
Momente im Alltag zu haben wo es einfach
schön ist die letzten Takte Morgen
liefert die Staatskapelle Musiker und
Interpreten werden sich dann gegenseitig
applaudieren so wird ein würdiger
Schluss Akzent nicht fehlen morgen Abend
ab 17:25 Uhr im ZDF
auch wer klein ist kann helfen das
beweisen jedes Jahr tausende von
Sternsingen die Spenden sammeln für
Gleichaltrige in Not weltweit in
Regensburg hat die katholische Kirche
die Aktion mit 32 Kindern gestartet seit
Beginn der Tradition ende der 1950 er
Jahre kamen übrigens mehr als 1,2
Milliarden Euro zusammen und jetzt sind
wir beim Sport trotz Corona weiterhin
volle Fußballstadien in England und
jetzt steht auch noch die Darts WM in
London in der Kategorie deutlich die
positiven Fälle bei den Spielern die
häufen sich der dreimalige Weltmeister
Michael van Gerwen z.b. musste deshalb
passen und er prangert das mangelhafte
Hygienekonzept an noch die WM soll
weitergehen vor vollem Haus
von außen wird der Ally Pally so
idyllisch doch drinnen steigt die große
Party so als gäbe es Corona hier nicht
3000 Zuschauer dicht auf dicht bei 30°
ohne Lüftungssystem die Athleten werden
feiert wie Gladiatoren negativer
Nebeneffekt dieser Schau 5 Spieler sind
bislang Corona positiv deshalb fordert
Titelverteidiger Preis zunächst die WM
müsse abgebrochen werden Ruder dann aber
zurück auch die Fans wollen auf das
Spektakel nicht verzichten
mittlerweile
nur dreieinhalb Meter trennen die beiden
Top-Favoriten nach dem ersten Springen
der Vierschanzentournee morgen geht's
weiter für Weltcup Spitzenreiter Karl
Geiger und den Sieger von Oberstdorf Liu
Jo, Jassi die Silvester Qualifikation
steht an in Garmisch-Partenkirchen
neues Glück könnte es heißen für Karl
Geiger am Nachmittag die Ankunft am
Hotel Riessersee wo es gilt die latente
Enttäuschung aus Oberstdorf
abzuschütteln immerhin verloren ist noch
gar nichts
sie bringen morgen um 1:45 Uhr hier im
ZDF und Langlauf schon noch mal Danke
schön und
wir haben jetzt noch einen kurzen
Rückblick mit ein bisschen Wehmut es ist
gewählt jetzt geht es nur noch darum was
für ein unfähiges damit anzufangen guten
Abend das war Claus Kleber heute journal
im Februar 2003 vor fast 19 Jahren
2976 Mal hat er seither das Journal
moderiert heute Abend zum letzten Mal
wie gehabt um 9:45 Uhr wird uns hier
fehl
das Wetter bleibt mild und wird windig
wogegen dazukommt sag gleich hinter Lea
machen Sie sich einen schönen Abend und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
Willkommen zu Wetter das Jahr ist nun
fast vorbei und das letzte ich ganz gut
mit den Jahren zuvor vergleichen es war
nicht ganz so warm das sieht man hier
ganz gut auf unserer Grafik hier dass
der kleine Balken dass du das Jahr 2021
fällt kürzer aus ist also
dementsprechend ich ganz zwar ganz so
warm gewesen wie die Jahre zuvor aber
man sieht einen eindeutigen Trend dass
es die schwarze Linien Deutschland wird
es immer wärmer diese Wärme begünstigt
Extremwetterereignisse wie z.b. die
Überflutung im Aartal in diesem Juli wir
schauen auf das aktuelle Wetter und
daraus scheint die vor allem über den
Norden Deutschlands durch bringt viele
Wolken und Regen mit und stürmischen
Wind um Südwest die Temperaturen der zu
sinken am Alpenrand auf -1° sonst ist es
ziemlich mild im Westen um zwölf Grad
morgen Tagesverlauf weiterhin viele
Wolken im Norden mit Regen teils
stürmisch als Sturmböen im
Nordwesten Südwest im Süden dagegen
sogar Sonnenschein da merkt man wenig
davon Temperaturen bis 15 Grad im Westen
16 Grad im Südwesten teils nur 10 Grad
im Süden Deutschlands nächsten Tage sind
weiterhin mild neuer teils trocken bis
14° ein schöner Abend